quand un patron fondateur d'une grande
entreprise a des problèmes de santé
c'est parfois tout l'édifice qui peut
vaciller c'est en tout cas la crainte
qui expriment les marchés financiers
autour de l'action apple depuis quelques
jours la raison de tout cela c'est une
annonce faite par steve jobs patron
charismatique de la célèbre marque
d'ordinateurs fabien shadow et guillaume
michel c'était il ya quelques mois
si jobs très amaigris à droite le même
il ya six ans avec quelques kilos en
plus
le patron d'apple dit souffrir d'un
déséquilibre hormonal
il quitte provisoirement l'entreprise
pour se soigner
conséquence plongeon du titre à wall
street et une question dans toutes les
têtes que va devenir apple
le succès de l'entreprise est intimement
liée à la personnalité de celui qui a
révolutionné l'informatique il ya 30 ans
quand il a 21 ans
steve jobs est conscient il le dit à
l'époque du fait qu' il est en train de
révolutionner la façon dont les hommes
vont vivre
il a inventé l'ordinateur personnel le
1er mai culte auch sort en 1995 c'est un
succès commercial
à 27 ans il est le plus jeune
millionnaire des est énorme
évincé dans l'entreprise à la fin les
années 80 il réinvente le dessin animé
et contretemps pixar toy story le monde
de nemo ou encore ac à tous y seront des
succès planétaires
apple est en crise en 1997 il est appelé
à la rescousse
quelques années il transforme
l'entreprise moribonde aux machines à
profit la plus rentable du secteur
sa recette l'innovation il invente des
ordinateurs qui ressemble à des objets
d'art la imac et sens où il s'impose sur
le marché de la musique en ligne avec
l'ipod certains et aujourd'hui grâce à
l'iphone
il fait trembler l'industrie du
téléphone mobile en quittant
provisoirement apple la question de sa
succession se pose
aura-t-il autant de talent pour régler
ce problème le sport avec le